and as Denise mentioned expected to
speak about 40 to 45 minutes and just
about to start and the big question is
how does he plan to get this done when
he's a republican governor and he's
dealing with a democratic largely
Democratic legislature so it looks like
everyone in the hall is standing up now
getting ready to welcome our brand new
governor Joe Lombardo from Clark County
so let's dip in now and listen to this
for the duration
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
Governor Lombardo we welcome you to the
assembly chamber and we look forward to
your message
well thank you
speaker Yeager thank you
majority leader cannizero
and baby
lieutenant governor Anthony
members of the Senate and assembly
honorable Justice of the Supreme Court
constitutional officers
congressman amade
thank you sir
distinguished guests my fellow nevadans
[Music]
good evening
before I go any further
we all know families are the Bedrock of
our society and I want to recognize my
family
first lady Donald Lombardo
and our daughters Morgan and Lacey
[Applause]
foreign
ly Morgan couldn't be here tonight but
I'd like to introduce you to my
one-year-old grandson Teddy
to my family without your support none
of this would have been possible
please give them a warm welcome
[Applause]
[Music]
we all understand the sacrifices they
make so that we can be here
their service to our state is no less
significant than ours
my sincerest thanks to your families
[Applause]
again the building upon the stewardship
of those elected officials who came
before us
I would like to pause to remember some
Nevada leaders who have gifted us their
legacy
congressman and state senator Jim
bilbray
Supreme Court Justice and lieutenant
governor Bob Rose
assembly men and county commissioner
David humke
assembly woman Jane Hamm
assembly woman in county commissioner
Myrna Williams
and state senator Spike Wilson
[Applause]
[Music]
in a special remembrance of Nevada who
served in the assembly 54 years ago
albeit for only one term
but a man whether you agreed with him or
not never stopped fighting for Nevada
all the way to the top the U.S Senate
Majority Leader Harry Reid
[Applause]
join me for a moment of reflection as we
extend our thoughts and prayers to the
Reed family and the families of those
whose generous contributions to our
state will be remembered
foreign
veteran I want to salute the men and
women serving in our military around the
globe
we should all be proud of the fact that
Nevada has a national Garden has
National Guard members stationed in
numerous foreign countries
as we sit here this evening our adjutant
general Andra Berry is in Romania
visiting the Nevada Army National Guard
137th military police detachment
our military families serve our nation
and tonight we honor them
and we honor their spouses and children
whose sacrifices help to keep us safe
[Applause]
[Music]
on behalf of a profoundly grateful State
we appreciate all they do to defend our
liberties our veterans deserve nothing
less than our best efforts
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
I'd like to recognize a veteran serving
in my Administration my budget director
Amy Stevenson Amy where are you
oh there she is
Amy is a disabled U.S Navy veteran who
has worked for Nevada for more than 20
years in numerous departments
please help me thank Amy for her service
to the state and to the nation thank you
Amy
foreign
[Applause]
looks like it's Teddy's bedtime
oh that's disappointing
earlier this month I said my inaugural
in my inaugural address or Nevada
history teaches us to persevere
While others settle for less
time and again we have gathered our
resolved and doubled our determination
when others tell us it can't be done or
shouldn't be tried
we instinctively do the opposite
as Governor I'm filled with hope and
optimism of what we can accomplish if we
simply summon the will to work together
it is my intention to work this to work
side by side with all of you
to write another chapter of Nevada
history that will record that we did it
the Nevada way
[Applause]
foreign
never give up and never stop dreaming
I'm here to say to you tonight our state
of the state is growing stronger every
day
[Applause]
but the pandemic
laid there just how vulnerable our
economy is
in an unexpected twist of fate the
pandemic also created for the first time
in many years an unprecedented budget
surplus
with this in mind my remarks will be
candid
on one hand we have exciting
opportunities within our grasp but on
the other
we must not allow ourselves to give way
to the temptation to overspend
we must remain dedicated to the twin
propositions of saving for and guarding
against
the next unexpected event that shakes
our economy and rattles our livelihoods
as a former Nevada named Samuel Clemens
better known by the pen name Mark Twain
once wrote quote
the secret to getting ahead is getting
started end quote
my fellow nevadans let's get started
[Applause]
my executive budget not only lowers the
tax burden on working families and
businesses but it also reserves more
than one dollar in savings for every new
dollar and general fund spending
[Applause]
it Bears repeating we will Reserve more
than one dollar in savings for every new
dollar and general fund spending
the executive budget reverses cuts to
some programs made during the pandemic
and addresses long overdue investments
in people programs and Facilities but it
does so responsibly
not a penny of the state's one-time
Surplus will be used to fund any
reoccurring programs
[Applause]
[Music]
for example by using one-time money to
fund 412 million dollars in deferred
maintenance and planning costs
taxpayers get safer more efficient and
more functional state buildings
my budget also saves taxpayers over 260
million dollars in interest payments on
bonds enabling us to among other things
create more construction jobs in future
years
[Applause]
a simple economic terms we're buying
with cash instead of credit
[Applause]
today the government has more money than
we can responsibly spend households and
businesses most certainly do not
look around everything is more expensive
these days groceries supplies and
services
nowhere is this more evident than at the
pump
the price of gasoline in Nevada has
averaged more than four dollars per
gallon in the past year
nearly one dollar higher than the
national average
I'm proud to announce my executive
budget suspends the State motor vehicle
fuel tax for the next 12 months
[Applause]
thank you
immediately reducing the price of
gasoline and saving consumers and
businesses approximately 250 million
dollars
[Applause]
in terms of the family of four that
translates to hundreds of dollars a year
in savings
working with local gas station operators
the petroleum industry and the Attorney
General's consumer affairs division
we will make certain that these these
savings exclusively benefit taxpayers
[Applause]
[Music]
using our budget surplus to provide tax
relief won't negatively affect our fuel
tax-funded Road and construction program
or impaired bonds
we must always remain mindful that our
financial Surplus comes from the pocket
of our constituents
okay there you go yes
as such we will not stop searching for
additional ways to return money to the
taxpayers
in that same Spirit my budget lowers the
modified business tax rate by 15 to 1.17
percent
furthermore my budget raises the
exemption for businesses subject to the
Commerce tax by 50 percent from 4
million to six million dollars
[Applause]
thank you
this represents the first time the
Commerce tax exemption has been adjusted
in favor of the tax taxpayers ever
these tax reductions ensure that Rising
prices don't create increased burdens
for Nevada businesses no sunsets no
Court decisions no gimmicks just plain
old-fashioned tax cuts that allow Nevada
to keep more of what they earn
foreign
the pandemic we drain the early
the rainy day fund almost immediately
reserves were not deep enough to Stave
off cuts to Education Health Care Public
Safety and other critical Public
Services
I regret to say but
Nevada will likely face additional
periods of instability
and we won't be able to nor should we
rely on federal bailouts to fund
government
you can clap I like that one
to protect us in the future my executive
budget increases Savings in the rainy
day fund from 20 to 30 percent
and
[Music]
and fully funds that account in other
words we will place another 630 million
dollars in the rainy day fund to be used
when dark clouds again gather on the
horizon
as I said before fiscal responsibility
is the backbone of my budget and I mean
it
overall my budget sets aside more than
two billion dollars in total savings
to safeguard against cuts to education
and critical programs in the years to
come
two billion dollars folks 2 billion
[Applause]
including those savings is 315 million
dollars for the Nevada way fund a new
sub-account to be used for
transformational economic development
projects and critical infrastructure
needs in areas such as emerging markets
in the North and South ends of the Las
Vegas Valley
as well as in other emerging markets in
Nevada
approval of the Nevada body funds will
be authorized by the newly formed Nevada
Wade leadership committee
made up of the governor and the
bipartisan leadership of the Nevada
legislature
the Nevada wave fund simply reaffirms
that we never stop dreaming and that we
are fully prepared to act on those times
when Market opportunity and New Capital
merge
thank you
in matters of our children's education
I think the best politics is no politics
[Applause]
let's agree to set aside politics and
turf guarding to deal with the stubborn
facts regarding public education in
Nevada
's public schools have been historically
underfunded and have historically
underperformed for our children
both of those facts must change
[Applause]
tonight I'm proposing the single largest
investment in K-12 education
and raising the bar on expectations and
accountability to the level not yet seen
in Nevada
my budget contains two billion dollars
in new funding for our students
[Applause]
that's an increase of more than 22
percent from what was appropriated in
the current biennium
that's two billion new dollars for
Literacy for instruction for our
children
perhaps most groundbreaking is the
commitment to equity when the pupil
Center funding plan was created Equity
was built into the foreign through the
weights for English language Learners
at-risk students and gifted and talented
learners
I'm exceedingly proud to announce that
my budget fully funds the targeted
weights in the pupil-centered funding
plan
streamlining those dollars to the
classrooms and students who need it most
[Applause]
and all is said and done my budget
proposed to spending more than two
thousand dollars per student more next
year
after years of celebrating a hundred
dollars here and there this investment
is truly historic
[Applause]
thank you
here's the tough part
along with this funny and I expect
results
I won't accept the lack of funding as an
excuse for underperformance
I'll be working with the state
superintendent to ensure our system of
accountability and transparency are
robust and enforced
and if we don't begin seeing results
I'll be standing here in two years
calling for a systematic change in the
governance and leadership in K-12
education
foreign
Nevada child has the right to a quality
education and should be college or
career ready by the time they graduate
high school
traditional public schools are not and
should not be the only option
private schools magnet schools Charter
Schools micro schools
virtual schools and homeschooling are
all viable Alternatives that can
increase the potential for Student
Success
my goal after we finish this legislative
session is to give Nevada parents
significantly more choice to make about
their child's education
I will be submitting legislation to
create the office of school choice
within the Department of Education to
ensure students and their parents have
the information they need to evaluate
every available option and that all
education providers are held to similar
standards
[Applause]
foreign
Center funding plan is built on the idea
that education dollars should consider
the needs of students and should follow
them no matter what school they attend
[Applause]
the inside government promoting the
expansion of school choice in Nevada
[Applause]
forward to working with Senator Heidi
Ganser
on expanding opportunity scholarships
she's been a strong and effective voice
on this Central component of school
choice and due to her leadership and
others
I fully expect opportunity scholarships
to receive a record amount of funding
this session
[Applause]
in total my executive budget puts more
money in public K-12 schools and
introduces more student and parental
choices than any budget in Nevada
history
[Applause]
teachers deserve a safe and stable
educational environment where they can
teach and students can learn
for the first time in Nevada history
we will allocate over 730 million
dollars to the education stabilization
account
which is a rainy day fund solely
dedicated to four K-12
thank you
interest from this account will be
innovatively used to provide
scholarships to Nevada high school
graduates who attend Nevada colleges or
universities and who are willing to
teach in Nevada schools for at least
five years
[Applause]
additionally Career and Technical
academies signature academies and Career
and Technical education programs should
be used to increase the pipeline of
qualified teachers
and to further address immediate
shortage we we should allow retired
Educators to draw both their retirement
and salary with no strings attached and
no unnecessary administrative hurdles to
clear
[Applause]
to help keep the teacher pipeline full
my budget includes funding for the
teacher Nevada scholarship program which
provides 30 million dollars in stipends
and tuition for student teachers
come on
that's a big deal that's a big deal
children who do not learn or read
proficiently in elementary school have a
lower chance of graduating high school
and a much higher chance of facing
difficult life circumstances and
creating a cost burden to the state
Governor Sandoval where are you
where is Governor Sandoval
there he is thank you
[Applause]
Governor Sandoval Champion Nevada's read
by three law in 2015.
the law was amended in 2019 and removed
a requirement that students failing to
meet proficiency standards in the third
grade be held back until those standards
are met
we need to reinstate adequate
accountability
therefore I will be imposing a new
five-year rule
schools have five years to improve
literacy scores and to ensure that
students who are not proficient in
Reading do not Advance beyond the third
grade until they are brought up to grade
level
[Applause]
there's a second issue affecting our
students literacy scores
far too many students are already behind
before they ever attend their first day
of kindergarten
my budget appropriates 60 million
dollars to continue and expand Pre-K
opportunities
[Applause]
the Department of Education will be
charged with open Plenty core Pre-K
programs
measuring results and providing policy
recommendations for a long-term strategy
to ensure more students are ready for
school when they get to school
foreign
nineteen the legislature passed ab168
commonly referred to the public school
restorative justice law
well intended this law has led to
instances of disruptive and dangerous
situations in schools across the state
in handcuffs School teachers and
administrators leaving them powerless to
address habitually misbehaving and all
too often violent students
this is unacceptable on several levels
most notably creating an unsafe
environment for teachers and other
students in the classroom
to be clear every child should be given
the opportunity to stay in school
but there are objective limits and there
should be no issue with temporary
removal of a disruptive student
resulting in an immediate meeting with
parents or Guardians
[Applause]
if classroom disruptions continue the
student will be expelled
[Applause]
we have two Nevada Educators from Las
Vegas and Sparks Among Us
who both recently experienced physical
assault in their classrooms
they're here tonight in an act of
advocacy for their fellow Educators and
to help emphasize the need for new
Safety and Security Protections in our
school system
thank you
[Applause]
these teachers and others teachers just
like them deserve our trust and
admiration
to those of us in this room and to those
listening and watching let's show these
teachers how much respect and support
and support we have for them thank you
thank you
[Applause]
thank you for that
we don't need any more examples of
school violence we've seen enough it's
time to act and repeal the most onerous
sections of this law
and in their place create structure that
works for educators parents and students
higher education plays such an important
role in the economic health of our state
among the stiffest barriers to
attracting new businesses and retaining
existing businesses is having a
Workforce that meets the needs of
business
to overcome this challenge my budget
restores entities operating budget to
pre-pandemic levels and sets aside five
million dollars to pay for the forest
study of the higher education funding
formula
[Music]
[Applause]
he probably won't smile after this
part of that funding study will require
to increase transparency and
accountability for higher education
institutions including their
self-supported budgets
foreign
it's been more than a decade since this
formula was updated and it's time for a
new formula to reflect the current state
of our system
we will also increase funding for
Workforce Innovation to better respond
to the needs of various organizations
for Workforce training
invest 75 million dollars for the
long-term stability of the state's
Millennium Scholarship program
foreign
65 million dollars in deferred
maintenance for aging buildings
put 20 million dollars more in graduate
student stipends and to support research
at our system institutions
[Applause]
nobody nobody clap for fixing the
buildings
it's not sexy right
[Applause]
at nine million dollars to build up the
faculty at UNLV medical school so that
we can accommodate more medical students
[Applause]
and appropriate six million dollars to
continue to stick for the state to
support
for promise scholarships four Nevada
high school graduates attending our
community colleges
[Applause]
thank you
there may be no more dysfunctional part
of state government than in the services
provided to our Workforce
delays fraud and system failures have
become commonplace
to fix it I'm proposing that we can
consolidate these Services under a
single office of Workforce
the office will develop and execute an
integrated plan and will oversee the 17
revenue streams source to the workforce
investment and Opportunity Act
right now we have five State agencies
the university system and local
governments and ministering over 200
million Workforce dollars they are not
aligned much less coordinated
right now we largely ignore the vital
connections between our Workforce
programs our public schools and our
colleges and universities
they must function as a single
integrated system
right now we have a state Workforce plan
that ignores the diversity of regional
economies
we have duplication of efforts between
non-profits and state agencies
we don't make it easy to access programs
to help would-be workers with
Transportation or or child care because
that's in a different department
right now we are wasting money but more
importantly we are wasting time and
getting all the balance the job
opportunities they deserve
the office of Workforce can be the
solution to this dysfunction
as a lifetime crime fighter
I could say there is arguably nothing
more important to the 3.2 million
nebadans in our state than public safety
[Music]
[Applause]
ab-236 from the 2019 legislature
introduced sweeping reforms on her
criminal justice system
at the time some changes I agreed with
and some I didn't but in the spirit of
compromise I did not oppose the bill
three years have gone by and we can
clearly see that some of those changes
didn't produce the outcomes
some were predicting
in fact they made things worse
to correct these problem areas I will be
introducing legislation that makes it
harder not easier to commit a crime in
the state of Nevada
foreign
[Applause]
holding career criminals accountable by
strengthening a habitual enhancement for
those offenders who repeatedly victimize
the community
strengthening the definition of domestic
battery by strangulation
protecting businesses by lowering the
felony theft threshold
empowering judges and probation officers
to impose tougher sanctions to let me
start over there
empowering judges and probation officers
to impose tougher sanctions for parole
violators
[Applause]
this allowing diversion for crimes
against children and the elderly
[Applause]
strengthening drug laws by reducing
weights for possession and trafficking
while increasing penalties
fighting the fentanyl epidemic
[Applause]
fentanyl possession in any amount should
be a category B felony
[Applause]
[Music]
addressing these problem areas will have
an immediate effect on reducing crime
and helps ensure the effectiveness of
our Public Safety and criminal justice
systems
if we look a little closer
there are clear disparities in Nevada
Public Safety compensation structure and
it's unfair
to address this we should make every
effort to retrain our public safety
personnel
therefore I'm proposed you can clap you
can clap
[Music]
therefore I'm proposing a two-grade
increase for all public safety employees
above what is recommended for all public
employees to help bring them closer to
parity with local agencies
[Applause]
[Music]
and to ensure we are no longer the
training ground for local government
police forces
[Applause]
thank you
we all know too well that crime is often
the result of poor decisions and
circumstances
incarceration should be the last resort
however jails and prisons are all too
often places where we house those we
have failed to educate failed to treat
or otherwise failed to get them the help
they need
[Applause]
[Music]
we are seeing the effect of this in our
streets in the form of increased
homelessness
we are seen it in our schools where
young people without access to treatment
are acting out
and we are able we are seeing it in our
economy where the safety of our
employees and customers is Paramount
we will make sure government does its
part by increasing reimbursement rates
in the area of acute need especially in
Mental Health Services
[Applause]
budget includes an enhancement in
Medicaid to expand community behavioral
health centers
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
expansion will add up to six clinics
across the state and underserved areas
including Northern and Rural Nevada
[Applause]
ensuring more Mental Health Services are
available to anyone in need regardless
of their ability to pay
[Applause]
the need for forensic Mental Health
Services is also critical
it's an area that has been neglected
my budget includes funding to convert a
portion of the city of Las Vegas jail
into a forensic Hospital
to build out a pod at the Ross and Neal
hospital for forensic services and money
for a brand new ground up forensic
Hospital in southern Nevada
[Applause]
I look forward to working with the
legislature to fund these projects
Nicole
[Applause]
let's talk about another issue that
might we must deal with candidly
the right to vote is one of the most
fundamental rights in American society
[Applause]
it is not only important that the
process itself has Integrity but also
that the people of Nevada have
confidence that the process is free and
fair
[Applause]
with that said there are certain
election reforms that are just common
sense
most notably all mail-in ballots should
be received by the time polls close on
Election Day
[Applause]
as opposed to five five PM four days
Falling In following an election I'm
sorry
Cisco gave me a dirty look
[Music]
this puts Nevada back in line with
national norms and ensures our election
reporting does not drag on for today
when the balance of the nation has moved
on
second Nevada created Universal melon
ballots as a response to covid
with the pandemic behind us this
expensive process is simply unnecessary
[Applause]
anyone who wants or needs a mail-in
ballot should have every right to
request and receive one
[Applause]
[Music]
sending ballots to more than 1.9 million
registered voters is inefficient and
unnecessary
not to mention it's estimated to cost
nearly 7 million dollars in this budget
and will increase to over 11 million
dollars in future budgets
third it is important to verify the
identity of Voters
[Applause]
foreign ature verification is a Time
intensive and cumbersome process
we require people to have a valid form
of identification to get on a plane to
operate motor vehicle or to purchase
alcohol and cigarettes Etc
but not to cast a vote in an election
this is illogical
[Applause]
fourth unregulated ballot harvesting
needs to be addressed to be clear
harvesting ballots was a felony prior to
the pandemic and now it's common
campaign practice
if we are going to allow someone other
than a voter or an immediate family
member to cast their vote in an election
that person should be clearly identified
and have some reasonable limitations and
Reporting requirements imposed upon them
finally Nevada needs to end partisan
redistricting
[Applause]
Nevada voters should have the right to
select or elected leaders not the other
way around
we need an independent nonpartisan
commission that is subject to the open
meeting law to redraw districts every 10
years it's time we do this
mark my words if the legislature can't
make meaningful progress in this
critical area these reforms should be
placed before the voters during the next
election
[Applause]
turning our attention to our state
employees
we have prided ourselves on having a
small and efficient state government
in fact the most recent U.S census on
governments ranks Nevada second to last
in terms of state employees per thousand
residents
no that don't don't apply for that
the sole purpose of state government is
to serve the people of Nevada
but this can't be done effectively
we have state job vacancy above 20
percent a remote and disconnected
Workforce and outdated computer systems
which is why one of the first things I
did upon taking my oath was to issue an
executive order requiring all state
employees to return to pre-pandemic
office hours by July 1st
[Music]
the truth is we ask our state employees
to do their jobs
but we're not paying Fair wages for a
fair day's work they deserve better
[Applause]
my budget includes an eight percent
increase for All State Workers next year
and an additional four percent increase
the year after
the last nine state employees received
even a five percent increase was 19.95.
and the last time they received anything
in excess of five percent was 19.85.
the increases included in my budget are
a major first step in sustainable
pathway increasing state employee pay to
where it deserves to be
[Applause]
moreover retention of our existing
employees is also critical
as such my budget includes two thousand
dollar annual bonuses for every
executive branch state employee to be
paid quarterly
they shouldn't have to wait until July
1st though
I've included money to pay out those 500
quarterly bonuses starting this fiscal
year
and I'm asking the legislature to pass
the supplemental appropriation as one of
the of its first bills to fund these
bonuses starting at the end of March
[Applause]
state employees also deserve a safe and
pleasant working environment
of the last three major State Office
Buildings constructed one has been torn
down the other is getting a new a roof
replaced and the grand Sawyer building
needs major rehabilitation
my Capital Improvement budget includes
funding for refurbishment of existing
buildings and money for three new State
Office Buildings so our employees can
provide services to our constituents in
a safe and stable workspace
[Applause]
priority of my Administration will be to
restore Nevada's reputation as a
pro-business pro development state
[Music]
okay
I think we can all agree Nevada should
be the most entrepreneurial friendly
state in the in the nation
[Applause]
unfortunately we've lost ground in this
area and it's our job to inform the
world Nevada has reopened for business
[Applause]
our best opportunities for economic
growth are providing a pro-business
environment for the 350 000 businesses
that currently call Nevada home and
offering a pro development invitation
for the expansion of new businesses and
industries
[Music]
[Applause]
whether it's closing the lithium Loop
unlocking Innovation and investments in
logistics entertainment science and
technology or embracing entrepreneurship
the message is that Nevada is ready to
partner
[Applause]
case in point
I'm looking forward to joining Elon Musk
and the team of Tesla tomorrow when they
unveil plans to build a brand new 3.5
billion dollar Advanced manufacturing
facility in Northern Nevada for the
company's all-electric semi trucks
foreign
[Applause]
matters I'm proud to declare that Nevada
is back open for business effective
immediately
[Applause]
with that said proceeds from our
economic Investments must be responsibly
and reinvested and we must Ensure
they are used to address the
transportation education housing and
Public Safety demands created by our
continued growth
tax dollars should be right should
rightly follow the demand for services
regardless of political boundaries
I am asking the legislature to work with
me to ensure that as expiring tax
abatements become new tax dollars
those incremental funds are directed to
the community's most impacted by our
state's growth
[Applause]
foreign
ly we all know Southern Nevada has long
been the entertainment capital of the
world and has become the mecca for
professional sports
this November we welcome yet another
spectacular International Event from
Formula One racing to inaugural Las
Vegas Grand Prix
[Applause]
please make welcome Stefano domenically
who is the CEO of formula one who
traveled from Italy to be with us
tonight and
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm looking to see if he'll let me drive
one of those things
and Renee wellm the CEO and president of
the Las Vegas Grand Prix
[Music]
we're excited to have you with us in
Carson City
and who had the race of races take place
in Las Vegas Nevada thank you
[Applause]
speaking of hospitality and gaming
concerns have surfaced related to a lack
of balance between the gold standard
of our gaming regulations and the time
required to gain approval from The
Gaming Control Board lab for new product
the result is that new products are
likely being introduced with more speed
outside of Nevada which directly affects
the competitive position of Nevada's
gaming operators
we need to work with the control board
to ensure the Log Jam is cleared
another issue of concern to our number
one industry is sb4 from the 2020
special session
that law imposed mandatory covid daily
cleaning and time off requirements in
our hotels that are no longer relevant
personal time off and daily cleaning
requirements add to the labor shortages
and exceed current CDC guidance
clearly much more is known today about
the transmission of the virus
than what existed when the legislation
was passed in 2020.
yet our hotel operators hands are tied
by this burdensome Legacy law and it
should be repealed
[Applause]
[Music]
let's make it one of the first
bipartisan things we get done this
session
[Applause]
one more issue from last session that
weren't Straight Talk
the public option was passed in 2021 but
won't be implemented until 2026.
I said it before passing laws that don't
have any practical effect is political
theater
serious questions will remain about the
rush implementation of the public option
agency amendments to the statute and
lack of transparency
getting the bad is insured is the goal
at a minimum this law needs to be
substantially revised or better yet
repealed
so we can refocus on the real problem
which is getting eligible but uninsured
Nevada is the coverage they need
I'll call your attention to another area
of Challenge and opportunity energy
California does not have enough electric
generation within its own state to meet
its electricity needs and is now relying
on the broader Western Electric market
to import energy
with California retirements units and
changing its transmission rules we have
no choice but to reduce our Reliance on
the market and seek Independence for all
Nevadas
to address this I will issue an
executive order that allows electric
providers to develop dedicated in-state
generation resources
to ensure that we are no longer forced
to rely on the broader Electric market
[Music]
our energy and it will spur Economic
Development
lead to job creation and drive lower
cost energy for all nevadans
[Music]
[Applause]
our greatest challenge over the next
decade may very well be water
put it all with it will require
partisanship and Leadership
partnership did I say partisanship
sorry
partnership
the Colorado Rivers there you go
the Colorado Rivers is in the midst of a
22-year drought and Lake Mead is at its
lowest level since 1937.
Southern Nevada's unique ability to
capture treat and return water to the
Colorado River
is a clear competitive Advantage but our
future is dependent upon our ability to
conserve and prioritize our use of water
it is also dependent on our ability to
work with the seven Basin States and
Mexico
to deal with the short and long-term
Water Resource Solutions
Nevada must lead by example and
demonstrate our firm resolve to achieve
a new balance on the river
going forward I will be more involved
along with Nevada's best water experts
in future negotiations with other states
purveyors and users to bring about
necessary change
thank you
at the same time we must apply the same
diligence and resolve to protecting Lake
Tahoe
so that future to generations of
nevadans can enjoy as much as we have
[Applause]
there is no simple solution to these
complicated Water Challenges
but we must be assured that our
neighbors share the same commitment that
we ask of ourselves
here
[Applause]
another issue that requires action is
the timely release of public lands
[Music]
[Applause]
currently
currently BLM BLM management has
jurisdiction of over 48 million acres in
Nevada
I would like to see us in coordination
with our Congressional Delegation
thank you
promote a more predictable approach to
the timely release of federal lands
[Applause]
the disposition of federally managed
lands within and adjacent to city and
county boundaries is a critical
component to Economic Development and
affordable housing
[Applause]
it has been said that the soul of Nevada
could be found in the people and places
that make up our rural
counties
I'm looking at you
staying connected to towns like Carlin
and Caliente gabs and gerlock and Wells
and Wadsworth
is a top priority of my Administration
to make this a reality I'm very proud to
announce tonight we will be making a 400
million dollar investment in Broadband
to accelerate Statewide connectivity
[Applause]
governor's office be knowledgeable about
rural affairs